[Laughter]
it's a perfect storm really the next one
could be covered 20 or 21 SARS MERS
Ebola free killer diseases that jump
from animals to humans I would say that
the possibility is extremely high that
the next infectious disease of humans
that comes is going to come from animals
probably wilder most scientists agree
covered 19 probably originated in
wildlife so how do they stop it
happening again and save lives in the
future
in Viet Nam's bakong Delta rats are a
cheap and populous snack while some wet
markets just sell vegetables and meat
many worldwide killing clean animals to
order elsewhere different types of birds
some wild
slaughtered and cooked rather customer
works they say the meters fresh some
argue is kinder than factory farming
since the news broke that coronavirus
may have spread from an animal market in
Wuhan the wildlife trade have been back
in this spotlight but even as we fight
one can demmick its fed we're opening
the door to the next in Indonesia's
northern Sulawesi province
despite the pandemic our crews filmed
bushmeat still for sale most of the
animals at these markets are already
dead there's charred dog
barbecued bats and snakes I got an a so
he's all
my mother
without water like a cauldron of
different species in filthy conditions
the environment is very high-risk very
high-risk they're not wearing gloves or
not wearing masks they're not wearing
overalls all of these different things
coming together live animals dead
animals keep the pieces of Alaniz humans
the conditions are absolutely perfect
for viruses it just needs a number of
different factors to come together of
the right at the right time and you end
up with a pandemic
officials at languange said they'd
investigate what we found and selling
live animals has been banned since the
covert 19 outbreak there are no plans to
close tomahawk market but roadblocks are
being set up to stop wildlife coming in
for food and people are being advised
not to eat it the World Health
Organization estimates that 60% of all
infectious diseases in humans come from
animals and kovat 19 has already killed
hundreds of thousands of people animal
welfare campaigners say the message is
clear wildlife trading must be totally
banned to prevent another pandemic
this is Chatuchak in bangkok home to one
of the biggest pet markets in Southeast
Asia well the smell is quite strong this
is how bird flu started one migratory
fowl bird and taken in the wild coming
into close contact with something that
we eat
we're here with environmental
investigator Steve Gow stirrer many
stools don't allow filming so we're
wearing hidden cameras some of these are
definitely gonna be some will be bred
but the virus does not discriminate
between legal and illegal animal here
domestic and exotic animals mix raccoons
and skunks hamsters nestled next to
hedgehogs it's like a high-rise block of
flats of different animals this is a
petri dish right here some of the
animals in markets like this are wild
and should never have come into contact
with humans and scientists say when you
touch them and sell them
it puts their bodies under a huge amount
of stress that means they're more likely
to pick up viruses which in turn they
can pass on to feeling sugar bear in one
shot we see a big cat a caracal in a
cage elsewhere South American capybaras
prairie dogs next America next to
Mongoose next to Cathy bear so these we
can
and punch to the world on top of each
other I think there is a real potential
for a pandemic jumping up from a market
like this because the same circumstances
are replicated here I think it's just a
matter of time these are ticking time
bombs so how do we lower the risk since
the corona virus outbreak China has
banned the eating capturing and trading
of wildlife and Vietnam is considering
similar moves the World Health
Organization's say hygiene and safety
standards and markets need to be
improved Thai authorities say they clean
and patrol the market and a new wildlife
law was brought in late last year but
officials believe change has to be
global Man Kong don't believe how God
blew up that Kong Kong let up man that's
hot man well they're very far they good
man yeah thank you
every what here Alabama deer type in
India let's go to the back we need to
end the commercial trade in wild animals
and we need to protect the habitat these
are the two main causes of kovat 19 come
on Edwin weak rescues trafficked animals
and unwanted pets do we have fleas I
don't have fleas do I hey hey hey there
are around 700 animals on this reserve
some were destined for the meat market
many were taken by poachers straight out
of the wild the illegal wildlife trade
is worth an estimated 23 billion dollars
globally every year but each time
someone goes into the forest and take
the wild animal out
that essentially bringing me virus to
stop zoonotic diseases you need to
control the wildlife trade but that
includes everything from legal sellers
markets tools and criminal gangs
whatever is illegal will always be done
behind closed doors in in dark alleys in
dark buildings behind walls where nobody
can see it
she can't see it you can't regulate it I
mean let's make regulations make sure
that it's very clear to everyone that if
you want to trade wildlife anything
gonna let it happen legally that needs
to be up to some kind of standard well
this is a Malayan son bear these bears
are taken out of the wilds for the beyal
farms in in laos vietnam and china cola
was rescued from the traditional
medicine industry a key part of the
wildlife trade today she's having her
annual health check-up china may have
banned the trading capture and
consumption of wildlife but bear bile is
now being promoted as a treatment for
covert 19 despite the lack of scientific
proof taking wildlife and other natural
resources out of these countries to
china
it's almost wildlife colonialism but you
see at the moment and the impact on the
world is is tremendous is horrible and
that's the problem there is no easy
solution thousands of income rely on the
wildlife trade and
say banning it risk pushing it
underground
but the campaigners and scientists I've
spoken to agree do nothing and with
sleepwalking towards another pandemic
humans never learned from the past they
keep people make these same mistakes
that's the worst thing about the most
intelligent species on earth we're the
most cleverest but we forget so easily
how much if the animals if the wildlife
is not going to survive we won't survive
I have little hope